european
cinema and culture are set for a major
boost
under the new creative europe program
the european commission
will increase its support to the film
industry and the culture sector
to 1.8 billion euro that's an increase
of more than 35 percent on current
levels
with the increased budget that we are
proposing tens of thousands
of professionals from both the cultural
and audiovisual sector
will be able to make the most of the
single market
as well as reaching new audiences both
in europe
and beyond without this support it would
be very difficult even impossible i
would say
for these people to break into new
markets
the commission estimates that at least
100 million people would be reached
through projects financed by creative
europe
between 2014 and 2020.
the cinema and audio visual sector would
receive more than 900 million euro
that's compared to 755 million under the
existing media program
and culture would get 500 million euro
that's a hundred million euro more than
now
creative europe would support two
thousand five hundred european cinemas
and the distribution of more than one
thousand european films
three hundred thousand artists and audio
visual professionals
would receive funding to reach new
audiences and it would enable the
european union
to contribute to the translation of more
than 5000 books
the european commission is also
proposing a 200 million euro guarantee
fund
which would allow small businesses in
the cultural and creative industries
to access up to one billion euro in bank
loans
every euro spent by the european union
in the area of culture
generates substantially more returns in
terms of quality of life
social benefits and of course in the
economy
creative europe supports and promotes
cultural
and linguistic diversity intercultural
dialogue
but it also promotes the europe 2020
objectives for jobs and sustainable
growth